Because of Biden,
I'll tell you that right now.
I'm not a political person.
But he's kind of messed things
up.
Ah, why is it so expensive?
A little intense,
a little insane, right?
$6.75?
So, yeah, you saw that.
So I'll probably just be putting
probably $10 just to get out
of here.
That's crazy.
That's too much.
Yeah, I think this is enough.
This is the only gas station
in Mendocino.
It's probably been here
probably near 100 years, one
of the first gas stations
and obviously it'll
be the last one if it closes.
How much is it today?
$6.78 a gallon for regular,
yeah.
[SQUAWK]
It's tough.
It's hard for people.
It's
hard for the elderly to afford,
you know, [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] you don't have,
you don't have money to spend
like this.
I do a half tank this time.
I think it's crazy.
It's terrible.
It's not necessary.
I'm retired myself.
So I live on a fixed income.
So these things matter to me
and my generation group,
you know?
I worked hard like everybody
else in my situation
did to be able to retire.
But if prices keep escalating
like it is, it's going to make
it very difficult for everybody
in California and the country
as well.
Well, the gas prices
in California are crazy.
It's a problem, yeah.
The price of everything
is going up.
But, you know, I feel for people
that have to commute to work
for a long distance.
It's made it so much harder
to get from place to place.
And I feel like I spend most
of my money on gas these days,
like gas and food.
So it's just kind of
frustrating.
I was pretty shocked when I
looked at the price.
I was expecting it to be like $4
something.
It's a little much.
You know, I mean, especially
with so many people that have
been out of work and things
like that.
And we had kids in their 20s.
And, you know,
it's hard for them
to go to the grocery store.
The people that are obviously,
you know,
running the whole situation, I
mean, politics, obviously,
money, that's the problem.
It's the taxes.
It's, you, know you could go
across the border in Oregon
and right away it's $1 a gallon
cheaper.
So we're overtaxed here.
Yeah, I don't know what to say
about our current president.
He's spending money, as we used
to say when I was
in the military, like a drunken
sailor.
So it's like it doesn't matter
how much he spends, he just,
he just prints more money
and taxes more of it,
you know, which, of course,
causes inflation to go up.
It would be beneficial to,
I'm sure, to America he would,
you know,
do something different.
You know, I was around in 1975
when inflation went crazy.
You know, I mean, it just went
like 30%, you know, 25%, 30%.
So most people are, a lot
of people have, they don't
remember that or they weren't
born then.
So it's going to take definitely
a bad turn in this country
and it needs to stop.
I think we just need to like
shift away from oil
and get more sustainable, you
know, automobiles, you know,
or just do a lot more bicycling
and things like that.
Gas over the years,
you know, it just,
it fluctuates.
It goes up, it goes down.
So it's just, kind of,
I guess I just think it is what
it is.
Having a lot of taxes
on that commodity
makes it really tough.
But, you know, you look
at this area too,
an average price of a house
is, you know, a couple
of million bucks.
So more tax on that those folks
might be a better way to work
that out.
Our volume is very low.
We have to pay for a $35,000
load in 10 days.
And if you're paying $4 a gallon
for gas if it's not marked up,
we're not going to be
able to pay for that.